[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello boys and girls uh welcome to
another episode of black man beyland i'm
mark bernard and i'm your host
uh as as always with these episodes
kevin smith is out in the world he's
touring clerks three he's off being
famous he's doing q and a's until three
o'clock in the morning he's making sure
that you love him as much as he loves
you um and so in the interim i i like to
hop on the feed and just to hey have a
conversation you know don't don't let
the feed go dry and still be able to
talk to you guys about the stuff that i
love and this week
um
we have a special guest we have uh uh
the man who ushered in the age of the
geek
baby
um
he uh i i have intersected with with our
guest host three times once he didn't
know about and then
a couple other times he maybe did uh the
first time was i uh i was a i was a
writer for entertainment weekly
and i loved this this comic book called
global frequency
and the the book was being adapted for
television by a fellow named john rogers
and so i emailed john rogers out of the
blue i was like listen man i want to
write for this tv show i'm not a writer
yet i'm just a journalist but i want to
do this and it's like hey
you should come to the set
and i said then i will come to the set
so i fly my ass to vancouver to the set
of the show that ultimately never got
made because
a new president came to the cw and
didn't like the old stuff and ruined
everything but i got to know john
roberts and then john
you know over the course of at this
point now like 10 or 15 years
would always kind of be in my corner
when i needed somebody in my corner um
and the first time that that manifested
was he invited me to pitch on a
television show
that he was then producing called
leverage
and uh and i said i'd love leverage i
would love to pitch on leverage what do
you look for in leverage like well i
need a heist i need a thing to steal
every week and i need you to make my the
stars of my show look good
and uh and i pitched in like nine
episodes of leverage and he didn't buy
any of them but
he kept inviting me to pitch leverage um
which you know the lesson there is
failure should not be an obstacle it
should just be incentive and so
every time that i pitched you know you
kept on saying all right it's close it's
not there yet you need a b c d and you
want to keep coming back and pitching it
never [ __ ] took but
leverage was the first time that i ever
saw aldous hodge on screen i was like i
like that dude like i like what he's
doing i like i like i like what he's
bringing to this show which is a flavor
that we hadn't really gotten to see on
television before which is uh
smart savvy stylish black nerd
and we had never gotten that before and
so to be able to live in that place
where hey i can see
myself minus three of those adjectives
every week then i will then i will
happily take it you know um and then the
second time i ran into aldus was in
comic-con
um i was at dinner at nobu with a bunch
of other black nerds and how this comes
walking by and he's like the black nerd
radar went off and then suddenly we all
started talking and we meet each other
and it was it was like we had known each
other for years because we all do kind
of swim in the same river
um and then the third time
was i think it was two nights later at
the entertainment weekly party at
comic-con um i got to be
a fly on the wall
for when aldous hodge met phil lamar
which was maybe my favorite moment of
all of comic con which is
no matter how no matter what your path
is no matter how you know you might be
starting as hawkman and black out a
movie no matter what it is we all have
those things that we grew up loving we
all have those those people
who were avatars of the things that we
that we were enamored with and invested
in
and
phil lamar as the voice of john stewart
in justice league you know
the animated show was that person for
lots of us and even before that he was
you know virgil hawkins and static again
that person for all of us in prison but
it's samurai jack he's been he's the the
goat of of animated voice work and so to
watch one green lantern meet another
green lantern and fan out over each
other was the most amazing thing that
i've seen at comic con in many a time so
when it came you know trying to to plan
what black man beyonce would be you know
in the span when kevin is gone i was
like i gotta see if i can get alex like
i think alice would be fun to talk to um
and and so we made it [ __ ] happen
because sometimes the world is kind and
the sphere is aligned and so welcome to
the podcast
alvis hodge how are you man
i'm good man i'm good how you doing
i am outstanding it is uh it is a
tuesday morning in los angeles um it is
one of us
is celebrating a birthday today
don't know which one you're talking
about i think it's jc happy birthday
chase
yeah yeah man it's uh
today is uh number 36 for me number 36
oh you must feel old
i know 36 i guess is technically
relatively young but
mentally
uh in life years and yeah i'm old as
hell yeah my grandfather would ask me
every year my birthday he's like how do
you feel and granted when i was born
he was like 80 years old
so
is that how you feel it's like i don't
know how i'm supposed to feel it's like
wait younger than i am so you already
feel good i was like well that's not
helpful
90 1100 years old man like what what are
we doing here but uh
yeah man me and birthdays i don't know
it's always weird i don't really
celebrate birthdays uh anymore i kind of
just like like try to let it
pass by but the people around me won't
let me pass it by they're like no we're
gonna do something we're going out
i actually every every year i always
used to say i just hope i'm working on
my birthday and eventually they start
coming past um
and uh i'm actually
this is where i'm comfortable this is
where i live with it but it's it's the
going out and celebrating that i just be
a little a little anxious about like
i'm good
yeah it's like you get there's the the
chunk of special ones when you're young
you know like you make your 10th
birthday that's a big deal
16 18 are big deals 21 is a big deal and
then they all start to be like we don't
really want to be talking about 30 right
like we're going to talk about 40 and
then 50 like i made it to 50. that's
great and then every birthday after that
it's just you're just not dead i guess
yeah i think for 50 i'll probably do
something uh
i'll probably rock out a little bit but
like i think after 25 i started making i
stopped
uh making the meal of it you know what i
mean because
it's just unnecessarily expensive for no
reason
i gotta spend all this money man
yeah yeah yeah man but you know i mean
i'm glad to see another year so uh you
know
it's it's been a brilliant year so far
you know it's been a big one man it's
been a big one but we'll get into that
to the bigness of it a little bit later
um
i want to know
which if not both of your parents are
from the caribbean
uh my father yeah
he's from saint thomas yeah yeah he's
dominican west india from santa monica
gotcha yeah because when i when i first
encountered your name like my my
grandfather
cyril lewis from trinidad my grandmother
eugenie holder from barbados
and so when i hear like
the like i've got cousins like mervyn
and alvin
yeah
like i hear that they out this
where'd you grow up
oh man uh born north carolina raised in
new york and jersey for most of my
childhood and
well in jersey was training hackensack
uh clifton which is you know like
i guess like around like passaic county
north carolina
um in new york it was mostly manhattan
man manhattan and then
uh for the last few years i mean i've
kind of been back and forth between la
and new york been in and uh
brooklyn for a little bit you know all
up and down brooklyn i mean
fourth grade best style you name it um
but i still got fam out there my pop out
there my brother's out there right now
yeah shooting the fbi most wanted so
um you know
he's uh he's getting it and um i know
he's happy to be back in new york
because i don't know so much about the
east coast man i mean i i'm cool with
cali i dig been here for a while but
east coast is where i feel uh
i don't know my nature you know what i'm
saying yeah i don't i don't get to spend
as much time back east because i was
born in the bronx
and then
um about 10 minutes outside of co-op
city
yeah yeah i got folks in port chester
yeah yeah so like i grew up there until
it was about 10 then moved to the south
shore of long island
um yeah and then into queens when i
moved out of my parents house and then
like got married and moved to new jersey
but like
for 40 years of my life it was the
tri-state area right and it was always
going into manhattan and like that was
the the beating heart of my whole life
was like how do i get to manhattan what
what train am i getting on how am i
gonna am i gonna take the the the long
island expressway am i going to midtown
tunnel at 59th street bridge like well
the 593 bridge is free so i gotta pay
for that so let's do that on the way in
and the midtown tunnel is free on the
way out because they're happy to let you
leave so
it's funny man how used to be the spot
to be and now it feels like
um ever since gentrification
[Music]
you know
brooklyn the bk is getting up i mean of
course we've seen what happened with
dumbo and and
williamsburg uh
nice area is just hella overpriced and
you know again i've been looking for
where my people at where where we at
start looking a little different
how do you like it don't feel safe
everything has changed
you know
it's crazy but um
yeah
it's uh
becoming a little bit more expensive now
or at least comparable to uh manhattan
so
okay you like this
anybody who bought it
on like two years ago is living right
now
like who wants to buy this i wanna i
wanna buy a yacht
i wanna live like jay-z for a while
somebody come and buy this two-bedroom
brand new
but yeah every time i go back every time
i can find an excuse to be back in new
york it doesn't even have to be for that
long like if i can be back there for
like two or three days like suddenly you
just start to feel it again right like
suddenly ah right i remember all this i
can i hop on this subway and there's
there's just something about that city
like new york city
and new orleans are these two places
that for some reason like and i've only
ever visited new orleans but it's the
it's that feeling of oh no this place is
old this place has stories this place
has history like you can peel back the
layers of both of those cities and just
start finding like strata of culture
and like it just that that that feeling
of it like you just walk down the street
certainly you're in a different
neighborhood with completely different
culture and like i'll need this food
here i'm gonna go up here i'm gonna do
this here and over there that's a little
bit dodgy i'm not gonna hang out here
you know but
yeah now i know all this man i spent a
lot of time there as well um was it just
there again this [ __ ] because that's
where we knock out uh leverage
redemption the reboot
so
yeah i spent a lot of time it took me a
minute to actually enjoy new orleans i
had to figure out every every city i go
to because i i'm a gypsy i move around a
lot
uh every city i go to i really gotta
figure out like what's my speed you know
where am i at where am i comfortable
and uh and all this it took a couple
years for me you know
but i finally kind of got the got the
town figured out so uh and i got a
couple restaurants that i really love
too i mean there's one called lillette
and then there's another one that's
actually i think owned by the same
people called bulani and box right there
nice so and i think they offer magazine
street i believe
but uh yeah man knowing this bro it's
just it got it got all right i started
new orleans after the pandemic and it
wasn't as crowded and it wasn't
like okay but then
you know
when people start getting back and and
you you got a lot of the locals back in
there and you know they start popping up
with the you know the uh uh
second line and all that kind of stuff
and and you feel it allows you to
appreciate the culture a little bit
because you've been devoid of it but you
know you get to cats out there in the
street playing music and jazz on every
corner you're like oh yeah this is what
the spot is about and it is the history
of that place that makes it what it is
yeah if they changed it they modernized
every part of new orleans and it's no
longer new orleans it's just
yeah like i love the fact that you can
walk down any given street in the french
quarter and see the french names and the
spanish names for each of the streets
because that's how this town used to
work and there's still those little
posts that have the horse heads on them
from when people used to itch up their
horses to go into a restaurant
like i i love that that at least it
hasn't forgotten
what it is one thing i don't rock with
down there and plantation houses well
every time i see one of them i was just
like
yeah
hey you want to go on a plantation tour
no no i don't
good
y'all let me tell you about the history
i'm good fam i know about that history
yeah exactly
uh tell me the
the first time
that you remember uh gravitating
something sort towards something that
was
comic book or science fiction where what
was your first nerd
um thing was your first fixation
born this
real way though i definitely got a shout
out uh john rogers yeah he will have you
back that brother he actually taught me
um
how to pitch and coach coached a couple
of my first uh
pitch meetings and um still i counsel
john is a source of knowledge and
guidance today so john is dope john
rogers is fired man so yeah
he's always been in my corner he's
always been like the first dude's like
hey you got a new thing i'll read it
you know
exactly that is john so
um but yeah the first thing i remember
uh
you know i tell this story religiously
but it's true i remember being three
years old doing a photo shoot it was my
first job and as a reward because i was
on good behavior my mom gave me a batman
toy and
you know again three years old and
growing up like
batman was it for me so
started doing work um
really because i was trying to be like
my brother edwin who was who had started
before me and then i just knew that you
know at the end of this job i'm
negotiating for a batman tour or a comic
you know so that's kind of where it
started but
batman quickly evolved into
batman spawn x-men primarily for
wolverine gambit and nightcrawler
um
bishop as well
uh
at a later stage
so
animation
pushed into anime a big anime head
i mean grew up on
[Music]
i mean
uh rurouni kinshin your yuaku show uh
gundam of course dragon ball pokemon
yu-gi-oh
um now i'm on all the dopeness like
demon slayer commissioner yaiba uh
jitsu kaizen i'm waiting for chainsaw
man like i need you to come on health
paradise come on get it together where's
the next season of one punch man where
is the next season of my hero academia i
need y'all to get it together
um because i'm a fan and i need my my
stuff but i'm all all over you know but
um then of course with comics and
graphic novels
the one that i really
dig down on that i'm not sure if not a
lot of people know about it's called
rising stars have you ever heard that
one
no
it survived man it's definitely a vibe
and uh
it's just good storytelling i saw that
and i saw
comics
i saw storytelling
in the graphic novel space
in a different way because it's the
first time that the idea of superheroes
were presented as human to me
always up to this point seeing
superheroes as
their own class
you know because they are in a world
where only they can understand but
rising stars was
it humanized these people who
were magnified this you know big
powerful you know
embodiment of what we think we want to
be it humanized them in a way that
um
i hadn't really seen before because it
gave him real human flaws and errors you
know what i'm saying
so
yeah uh
that was pretty dope but yeah man i mean
and then of course grew up on video
games and all that i need them to do a
super updated version of skies of
arcadia because that's dope final
fantasy my [ __ ]
all day i'm sorry you opened a can of
worms bro like no it's listen i've been
walking down the can of worms aisle like
hoping we would start cracking some of
these
in his imagination and now i'm still an
adult who lives in his imagination it's
a beautiful thing man like it's it's it
is a very narrow slice of the world
where you get to actually be
a person who like oh no no no no this is
what i do
i get to i get to kind of play even when
it's work it's play exactly yeah yeah um
i feel like i'm gonna need the alice
hodge anime uh
sort of primer because like i i dipped
into anime early like i was a ghost in
the shell kid i was an akira kid i was
like going into the film forum at
midnight to go and see akira when you
couldn't see it anywhere
did you watch ninja scrolls i watched
ginger scroll oh yeah
okay ninja scroll and i mean obviously
naruto but that's like
classic so yeah yeah yeah like that and
then there was like a then there was
like i think it was like after you know
the looping stuff and i got into the
miyazaki stuff but then there was this
weird minute where i i guess it was a
a brick that me and anime had for like
10 years and then once you do that
it is like impossible to dig back in
because
you know
i guess all right i'm trying to attack
on titan all right this looks kind of
the what is happening here all right i'm
gonna try i'm gonna try whoa
okay
i mean i will say attack on titan is
actually pretty dope that's definitely
one that's on the list um if you are
looking for good fight choreography and
fighting move
um guys of high school i think is really
ill because i grew up a fighter i was a
martial artist and a lot of times i look
at
practicality you know how are they
composing the fights and all that you
know i'm looking for different angles
you know and all that kind of stuff and
uh
yeah man guys in high school is pretty
dope combat um
it's not an anime it's a video game but
it needs to become
a movie please and an anime soon but um
it's
of course
metal gear solid i mean that's like
top tier they need to i i wanted to do
uh
i wanted to
acquire the rights to metal gear and
make a movie out of it but of course the
rights were already being held but
that as a movie on a massive i'm talking
epic
star wars level is going to be the
highest property out because there's so
many people that though the storyline
and
god dang it rave like ah man snake it's
it's uh their villains were amazing
and uh
storyline was pretty dope but yeah it
was it was hot it was hot yeah i i have
those memories of like one o'clock in
the morning on my ps1
playing metal gear and then being kind
of trapped into like a 20-minute cut
scene
and i was like man i just wanna let me
save the game i just gotta go to sleep i
gotta get up for work in the morning but
oh damn all right i'm gonna sneak into
this building
exactly
and uh what is it it's uh ryden right
ryden was like the
cyborg it's like oh man uh
that that to me
if it was done as a film
it's competing with the game they would
have to be so excellent with how they
just knock out the action sequences and
all that kind of stuff because that's
what i live for i'm like can i see
you know because the video game their
cut scenes were i'm talking yeah
incredible so they wouldn't need to
really
match that or step it up behind beyond
it
um
but yeah i get i get very passionate
about
because i grew up on action films and
being a fighter i always
looked towards
the i mean you know when i was a kid it
was
uh
of course like you know gently jean
claude van damme uh
it was
challenging fat
yen
um
now most recently eco y
uh
uh tony jia
i mean these are incredible athletes um
i mean equal why i found out about him
from the raid redemption which is my
favorite
fighting movie and
right because the choreography is insane
and along with that camera work it was
creative stylistic it was storytelling
it was narrative well the camera work
and the fighting work in in a really
fantastic way so that is is top tier for
me but um
versus the red
one versus two you like two better than
one
the red one is my top
all right
that's the omg ray 2 is good but it's
just like on bach they did a sequel to
that the first unbox is my top tier yeah
um
what is it
what is it man fall for you
it man is up there because i actually
practiced uh i trained in wushu when i
was a kid so iphone is up there i can't
tell you which hip man
there's four of them i believe i've seen
three um
so i'd have to figure out that last one
but the first one
really does a good job of
i think
going into the store oh no actually i've
seen all of them but the first one it
just
i think it's a really good storytelling
point about
the the sort of the inception of the
style from a poetic
perspective and not super commercialized
and overzealous and overdone i think
they did a really nice subtle job with
it but
they also highlighted the
beauty and the fighting style
because
going from
southern shaolin kung fu into jet condo
and then wushu jukando is sort of a
subsidiary of more of a street fighting
style version that was um developed by
bruce lee right so with wushu
um as a base there's a little more flow
super powerful but there's a little more
ease
you can do is really quite nice but it's
also a little faster a little sharper
and
um
there's a little more elegance when it
comes to
wushu i mean if i'm in street fight i'm
choosing either muay thai or g condom
getting at it you know what i mean if
i'm competing or if i want to really
accentuate movement for a camera i'm
going to wish you because you get
beautiful flow and it's almost like
you know fighting ballet or something
like that um
again i get passionate about these
things
no i'm i'm here with you man because i
i have some ears on you so i i grew up
in i was born in 71
and sort of that late 70s early 80s
especially living in new york it was all
about bruce lee it was all about kung fu
movies it was all about 36 chambers of
shaolin it was all about five deadly
venoms it was all about like you know
the peaking opera style of kung fu which
is far less applicable to anybody
because it's a dance
which is fine
but it was everything like it was it was
action that you'd never seen before
because like guys are flying through the
air and the kicking was never a thing
that happened before you watched cowboy
movies and it's just the same two or
three punches and suddenly these guys
are having 10 minute long fights
you know they those were my first
superhero narratives were comfortable
you know like i went to that before i
got to it was like that in godzilla was
my entree point
and then like later on i would discover
like the x-men and spider-man and secret
wars was my jam early on and then that
led me to like all the rest of them all
the universe and then eventually got
into dc but i i entered that
as like star wars kung fu and godzilla
or the holy trinity
and so then like action cinema also
became my cinema like and then you get
the 80s you get all of the nonsense that
would appear on home video that you can
get like all right sure blood sport this
looks good but then there's 19 other van
damn movies that have since lost any
theories about martial arts i'm just
like i'm gonna
do this split kick and hit two guys and
that's that's the thing yeah
um let me ask you something have you
seen a movie called only the strong
is that
is that uh michael j white
no no mike mike is a adult martial
artist as well yeah
and uh what is it uh i think his name is
scott atkins who's insane um but only
the strong
is about capoeira
and man that was my first induction to
complain
when you watch that movie uh
there's this one brother right now
uh
who
is crazy insane with capoeira i believe
it's
the
feet the latin
latif crowder i believe his name is
um i might have that wrong but uh he's
an insane martial artist but capoeira is
his jam and
i mean that brothers and he's
talked about an athlete but when you
when you look only they're strong
that was my introduction to
understanding even what it was
and
yeah man i would i would definitely jump
on i'm trying to think of who
ha
who's starring in it because
i know
the name is on the tip of my tongue and
we have google for all these things
that i can't remember the name of
but uh who i'm sure is who alec hardison
was named after but
probably
yeah
yeah kadeem was a good people
yeah but i remember that movie was
selling who is this dude mark to
costco's like he's killing it
and now he's hosting iron chef because
he's got to get that money
which is another one of my loves man
grew up cooking and iron chef was my jam
bro
all right jeff was everything
i love cooking show
i mean i i the pandemic was a big deep
dive into like i'm gonna watch all ten
ten seasons a great british bacon show
i'm gonna catch up all these master
chefs i'm gonna watch a lot of hell's
kitchen like i went
hard
see i don't really bake uh much at all
my baking is non-existent i'm just
keeping the honey so
i don't really watch the bacon shows as
much right but the cooking shows i mean
iron chef was it um
uh
god what is that um
chopped chopped is one of my jams
because i like how people just go and
they get because my brother and i we
grew up cooking you know island boy like
you know that's what we do right
we get up in there get some random stuff
and try to make magic man we used to get
in trouble staying up late at night
watching cooking shows my mom used to
come in the room like y'all know they're
gonna be watching that scanner max
i'm trying to
it's been contessa like she's just doing
some [ __ ] in here you know
and i'm trying to
make this white wine sauce you know
[Music]
um but uh
emerald lagasse back in the day was
it was like
that's what i used to get in trouble for
bam
god damn the bam um
but like so so tell me how a kid you
know growing up
you know
an actor a performer very young right
like he wasn't [ __ ] around like you
got in there early
girl got in there early you know grew up
a martial artist an athlete you know
like
why has your resume not been filled with
these kind of movies man like why have
you not been
[ __ ] punching [ __ ] in the
face
a lot
i have no idea i've always wanted to be
part of um you know some kind of action
movie just because that's what i grew up
on and what i wanted to to
experience you know
from the point of being a performer and
also from the point of just being
somebody who appreciates it and i look
at things with a keen eye to figure out
how to elevate
where
we've been to where we're trying to go
because i know what i want to see and
when i see it done well
you know that becomes a different thing
like that's why when i see the raid and
i watch how the fights are composed boom
it makes sense to me because i'm like
this is an elevation now can we do this
in a a grander way right
um
when i watch a movie like extraction i
see
the camera movements
being executed in a whole different way
the the visuals on that the the
cinematography was for for for stunts
for action insane you know so
me i've always tried
but for some reason
my my career has led me down a different
path and it took me a little longer to
get to here so now you know with
black adam i actually have a grand
opportunity to really
just experience that flex my muscles a
little bit
and dive into what that world is and i'm
just grateful to even have that
opportunity at this point you know
but um man i've always tried but
i remember
i was just never i don't know if i was
just never the guy or never
had the appeal the look that you know
what i'm saying but
your timing is your timing and my timing
is
is well i say this my timing has always
been but my timing to jump into this is
right now uh so tell me a little bit
about the blackout experience for you
like tell me
you know i mean i've seen on the
instagram i've seen me like you know i
get the call from from dj he's calling
me telling me to be in a movie but like
what was the audition process like when
when when did somebody say hey so they
got this movie
called black adam is it a thing you know
anything about do you want to get down
on it do you want to audition for it
like oh
no it was really more like a
meeting first between uh
zhang and the director and i um i read
the script and they wanted me and jama
to get on the horn and
just uh chop it up see how we felt see
if there was some synergy and drama is
mad cool you know um but right off back
you know from the first conversation i
could tell that he was already thinking
about how to make improvements he was a
visionary and uh
that definitely shows through the film
because man this film is insane
yeah it's it's dope man but uh
it was just really trying to figure out
the vibe and then after that uh you know
putting some words on camera just to
feel just sort of you know producers
could feel how my approach to the
character was
and i remember there was a part of me
that was so in my head and nervous about
it that i probably no not probably i
actually did
uh it was a self tape and i was in new
orleans
um shooting leverage so in between
shooting you know i went snuck off to
the little casting joint to put myself
on tape and then i was at home putting
myself on tape
i ran that tape over 300 times before i
submitted because
this was like
too comfortable of a situation
it's not like oh hey you got the job
it's just like you know
you're very close to it and in your mind
you're like okay this is mine to lose
i always think that i'm not the only
consideration i'm not the only but when
you know there's a lot of favor and a
lot of support
carried with you in the room
you're like now i gotta really it makes
you even more nervous you know
i'm more comfortable when the odds
but
put the stuff on safe
re-record several times
and then after that you know waited a
couple weeks it was kind of radio
silence and i realized uh dj wanted to
he was working but he wanted to be the
one to call me so he took time out and
he actually called me the day after
my birthday in 2020
uh what was that 34 i think
yeah
so so he called me the dad for my
birthday i was like like i told you i
always want to be working on my birthday
like i just got a a
i got a crazy insane job then um
i just got
a really fantastic job now and again on
my birthday so manifest that stuff he'll
be specific
that was the process man and
uh when he told me i did feel like it
was low-key winning the lottery i met
well i imagine what i i would imagine
winning the lottery is like because
it was a feeling of euphoria i had never
felt before in my career that oh we
finally because i've been trying to
knock down action films forever i've
been trying to get in the superhero
universe
for like 15 years at that point
you know trying to just jump in i was
grabbing at every audition or trying to
there's a lot of auditions i couldn't
get you know
so for me
it was the culmination of all that
effort and sometimes often embarrassment
um
[Music]
coming to fruition and saying okay this
is what it was all about you know it's
preparation and also don't give up
because you'll ever know what's what's
in store for you like
with opportunities i wanted before i
realized it would have been
it would not have been this experience
for me and this has been an amazing
beautiful and wholly unique
experience for me because with this film
we're at the precipice of being able to
start something we get to begin
something new
and what we get
uh an opportunity to to
introduce
um for all of us man is
really
i think in a creative way quite
superlative but as an opportunity really
unique and amazing and
i'm just excited you know it couldn't
have happened in a better way so it's
the whole process for me the
black adam experience is great
shooting is great the cast is incredible
they're amazing human beings off screen
and you know couldn't be more grateful
for that because
for something like this to work you
really need everybody to be
just gracious
and everybody was there to have fun
um
you know but our producing team is
amazing uh our director again jamaica
lacera he's awesome man dj is great so
it's been a really
nice comfortable experience um
you know
felt support supported the the entire
way
i don't think i could ask for it to be
any any different you know and that's
not it's not blowing smoking nothing
like that it's just being honest about
the fact that
i've been in some situations that were
tough and i'm
as big as it is i'm grateful for this
one to be exactly what it is yeah now i
i i love the idea that that for you
winning the lottery is going to work
yeah you know and because for some
people like when the lottery land would
sit on my ass for the next 40 years and
just find a way to spend this money
but
i
i have a problem with the
idea of vacation or taking a break
um it's how i was raised i mean again
i've been in this business since i was a
kid it ain't all been pretty and flowers
so the hustle is up and i do need to
learn how to
and
adopt the idea of vacation
but for me
my work is my passion and i formed all
of my hobbies into my streams of revenue
so i don't feel like i have to go to
work every day right
um
and for me
the opportunity to be creative in this
way that is the real
lottery for sure
because
i have to grow i have to expand and and
evolve as a performer as a businessman
as an actor
um just as a man myself right so when i
think about all that opportunity i'm
like damn this is growth in so many
different areas i can't even
uh uh
put into
words um
but the opportunity for that is rare
doesn't come around a lot you know i
don't get to be comfortable in this
space when i come about ahead
my potential is now magnified to a point
i can't even understand
so that's what i went in to the game
looking for when it came to this shoot i
was about to be prepared ready
about to learn everything i could learn
and you know those 15 years of trying to
jump into this very specific genre
was all preparation so i'm not going to
waste that now we going to work
you know you tell me hey here's a mark
where you have to do nothing no
no we're not doing that
uh what what is it like preparing to
have to take your shirt off
in a movie with a rock in it
oh man well
i i can't say if i take my shirt off in
this movie
i can't say
spoilers man just give it away
that was grueling but also
the worst part about getting your body
prepared is disciplined with when it
comes to nutrition
and not
like you have to be super specific and i
had a short amount of time to do it too
like i
had maybe
i would say from the time
of
i think i got cast and i got cast in
september 2020
we went to picture around april may
right so it was training all the time
but you see somebody like the rock he's
been doing that for years
you know
everybody did he made like that you get
a few months
you got to put your body to a lot to
transform you know muscle don't grow
overnight or over a week or over you
know you really in terms of expansion
and forming it it takes training the
body to to become
like it's like i call it metabolic
tricking
you gotta
prick your body um when i love the
nutritional part because working out
being in the gym pumping weight says
nothing is easy
i think cardio is quite disrespectful i
cannot stand running gets on my damn
nerves
running tries to kill me every time
um
but
uh
when it comes to
like understanding how fat works in the
body and cutting fat in certain areas
that's nutrition man and that's where
you got to be most disciplined
so you probably have a little person in
the back
i got a little squishy person who's
probably angry about feeding right now
no squishies
uh yeah all right i got a couple more
questions for you things to talk about
before we let you bounce and enjoy your
birthday and your squishy person
um
i i did find it ironic is the wrong word
because i don't think it's it's irony
but you're playing hoffman
yeah
the egyptian god
of
that looks like a hawk is named horus
yes and you are deep into horology
yeah see what i did
how did that happen for you
horology like was that a thing you've
always been interested in time pieces or
is that a
new thing yeah i i'm a creative nerd
through and through um definitely not
super smart but i'm an applied
mathematician that means that
if you give me a book on math i don't
know [ __ ] i'm not gonna remember nothing
if you give me something to do with math
then i'll be able to retain the
knowledge i started in architecture i
mean when i was 13 i used to intern at a
firm for from 13 to 15 and turned out a
firm in santa monica
and i worked on projects
then um after a few years of college
because i started college when i was
like 14.
by the time i got to art school
um i was going to be there for
architecture and product design
and
that matured into horology because
i could take it with me while i was
still acting with architecture i would
have to quit
um with
neurology it was architecture chemistry
um micro mechanical engineering and art
all formed into this one ball that for
me
was a way i could
eloquently express my
my opinion my my love for and celebrate
my culture through this piece of work
you know so i had to learn a completely
different science um still learning it
had to learn well i'm terrible at french
but i'm still learning french as well
uh it's a necessity even i'm just lazy
um but i just love the design part i'm
old school with it man and uh
it it allows me to have a different kind
of conversation culturally um and it
gives me a different
outlet for creative expression so that
when i'm down in other areas i
acting entertainment all that kind of
stuff
i have an outlet that
gives me a sense of space and freedom
where i feel whole and full and and
warranted because you know
art creativity that's my language if if
i can't
you will usually catch me in the streets
with my drafting book and a pencil and
if i don't have them next to me i
low-key
feel like i'm missing something like i
get anxious you know
um because i'll design whatever
uh
and and that's what i still love i still
want to rock with different brands now
on the art directory side or whatever
and collaborate designing
anything from products clothes just
because i like giving people a new
perspective on how to engage product
uh familiar product in a very new way
refreshing way
but right now
watchmaking is
such
it's such a cultural and a life lesson
in many forms
that it's it's teaching me to again
evolve and i like to put myself in
uncomfortable positions
not dangerous but uncomfortable
positions
unfamiliar positions in order to grow
i also have an
unbearably
consistent knack for wanting to do
difficult things i don't know i don't
know why
well i mean every every new role is a
new problem to solve right like every
every new story is its own kind of watch
you gotta make like it has an internal
there's an internal map to it there's
there's some some engineering to it you
know like all of these gears have to
mesh otherwise the story doesn't work
um yeah they're not that dissimilar when
you think about it they're really not
the approach is not
necessarily uh
that the approach can be to to both can
be similar in terms of the approach to
the work of
watchmaking and horology versus the work
of like acting
the expectation of outcome is different
because with watchmaking math has to be
absolutely perfect there's no room for
deviation if you're off by a .02
millimeter minimum
then
the watch is off you know it's either
not working or it's off a few seconds of
gaining too much time it's all that
right
with
people
perfection is
messy
so you have to allow yourself to be
like math one plus one is two that works
for watchmaking with humans one plus one
is
five and you're like the [ __ ] you know
but
you gotta go for that road to figure out
how to get back to two you know and it's
because people are messy confusing and
they're not
they're not exact and they're not always
predictable which makes them
uh
human
so
the
understanding of what
to expect in terms of the sum
of this creation it's it's as long as
you realize
what field you're playing in then you
know you're not going to be surprised by
them by the result but
at the end of the day i do break down
people and these characters
um
technically
uh
to a degree
i'm really not as far as like backstory
and things like that i'm not too
specific sometimes
um
i go off of honest intention for where
they are you know backstory fills out a
lot of
what happened in the past if we're
touching on that then that's something
you know we can really figure out but
for me mostly like of course with
playing you know carter hall and and
black adam
has a rich backstory and we have to
figure out which backstory we're going
into and how this shapes them because
that is wholly
who he is is wholly dependent and is
determined really by his history
so now what does he do with that history
going forward so there's a situation
where i have to be fully fully
aware and short backstory then there's
characters where
they don't know who they are and they
don't understand what their backstory is
so they
need to figure out who they are from
where they are and we're discovering
what life is we're shaping them as we're
going along the journey
um again different approaches to
whatever is being asked
but at the end of the day
there's a process for approaching each
kind i think you need to
strongly define
um
understanding
what the job is and how to really get
the best out of that that particular job
i
you know because the the free part of
creating when it comes to watchmaking
the free part is the first part which is
okay you understand how to make a watch
how to make a watchbook okay cool
where's the design i can where's the dna
that people have done that
cannot be technical at all that's the
part that has to be messy and organic
for you to really find a design that's
indicative of you because i was a
conceptual designer for a number of
years designing around the same
movements that everybody in the industry
uses and it's hard to be unique in that
way because it's thousa hundreds of
thousands of different it's hard you
know you have to fight to be
unique and um
deliberate
when when when people
look at your design
there has to be very specific and
deliberate intention there
and uh that's with any design really
because that's your mark sorry i can
again i can like
all day
no that's i all i wanted to do man was
opening these cans of worms
i got another like 15 20 we can keep
pushing brett you know because
just let the the little chubby person is
fine right now
like you just you just eyes go wide
we're like we gotta go like shit's about
to melt down in that room i need to be
off of this
right now
there's happiness i need to maintain
um
do you do you like going on press tour
like i know that you're about to launch
into what has to be this massive
international tour in support of black
adam right is that a thing you dig
i do dig here's what i say to people um
to young actors a lot even even some
actors have got a little a little life
on them
and they don't like to depress they
don't like to do that part i'm like your
job is not done when they roll
you know
cut on the last frame you've only shot
the movie now you got to sell the movie
but if you feel like being a part of
films you got to be a part of the whole
package and if you are invited to be on
a press store that's actually a great
privilege i've been a part of a lot of
projects that
i was never considered when it comes to
the press tour nobody want to give me
love and i cool whatever i get it um or
you could be on the press store and
you're not prioritizing you're just
sitting there wasting your time you're
like
why am i here
so the opportunity again the opportunity
not the obligation but if you get the
opportunity to be on a press tour and
actually speak on behalf of what it is
you're doing and
that is a an amazing
uh sort of
check benchmark rather of your career
for
elevation you know to say that now i've
gotten to this place where
somebody's entrusting me
to
go represent this project and hopefully
i don't say the wrong thing to mess it
all up yeah
i love her i've never been on a
worldwide press tour before i've been in
the game 33 years and this is my first
first worldwide i've done press tours
around uh america around the nation but
um
yeah man it's uh
this is gonna be cool i'm looking
forward to what exactly is about to
happen and and how it's really going to
go down but
um it is a lot of work though the press
tour sometimes seems harder than
shooting the the film sometimes just
because
you're moving man it's like you you're
on a concert you in here boom you do
press from
eight in the morning to like six seven
at night then you know
depending on your schedule you might be
on the next playing out in two seconds
so it's a lot of work but i enjoy it
yeah and also the
how can you find
48 different ways of answering the same
question
so that that's what
i have a tough time with that is that is
where it's like i want to say
something different so that people don't
see like 48 interviews of me answering
the same exact way but how can i
say the same thing in a different way
where it's still the same answer so
people get
you know what i mean
um
and
outside of that like
i don't know if the questions are
screened prior but i would think as a
journalist you'd want to ask the most
i guess it's hard to say unique question
but the most
what is the one question you can ask
that you know you're the only one with
you know what i mean the only you have
the only conversation about boom head
and
i get i i get those are probably really
hard questions to figure out to come up
with so
it's a tough job on both sides but yeah
man i've been trying to like
i'll be trying to try to
i don't know i'm like answering
yeah so how do i say
how do i order coffee
17 different ways so aldous were the
wings heavy i'm sure is the question
you're going to get
more often than not like i've been on
that other side i never did i never did
junkets a lot because i always kind of
hated that um i was never a person
because i was a journalist for
25 years
um
and uh i worked for someone weekly in
the la times and hollywood reporter and
like i was an editor more than i was a
writer so i was never like the cat well
i was the guy sending people to to
junkies not the cat who actually went to
jumpers um
unless i got to talk to writers i would
i would do a junket to talk to writers
because then you get to ask all like
that hey tell tell me how you [ __ ]
did that like that was my first question
because i talked to the endgame guys i
talked to to um
to mcfeely and marcus and it then it
becomes just a question of craft right
then it's like you know what are the
pressures on you what are the what could
you do what couldn't you do when do you
know that you're gonna kill this
character off whatever that is it gets
like dense that way
hold on one second oh
we knew it was going to happen
and we knew it was going to happen
exactly when he said it was going to
happen
it's like 1102 yeah the eyes went wide
yeah
yeah
uh
while we have alice taking a quick break
i'll jump in i want to share a couple uh
comments from chat that i really enjoyed
oh look at that my uh my bam finn is all
screwed up here
oh we're back okay i don't need he's
back
did somebody hug
no but uh but consider i mean i i would
imagine for you
that's where you you thrive just because
as a writer you're like his i'm about to
start farming for education yeah then it
becomes hopefully it becomes a
conversation and not a question and
answer right that's that's what you
always hope for i think it's hard to get
that because you've got six minutes
opposite of doing a director's chair
who's got another train of people behind
him so
if you can find that one question that
you can like i bet you nobody's asking
that and then you get that feeling of
like the life preserver eyes like thank
you for not asking me if the wings were
heavy thank you for
having done some [ __ ] research but
without anything else to talk about you
know
did we lose somebody
uh it looks like we lost him we lost
alice
all right i will just keep telling that
story um
you know the the fact that like every
question is the same if you can come up
with that one question to make a person
who's listened to 58 different
variations on the same thing
over and over again smile and just like
oh thank god all right let's talk about
this it's not about anything else but
this
um
that's that's
that's a little like feathering your cap
that's a little moment of grace
i think for both parties concerned where
it's just like oh
man alive
a different question
and also you know
you can
as the person on the receiving end
kind of reframe the question to talk
about whenever you really want to talk
a little bit of a secret you can kind of
reject the premise of the question and
then just kind of say well yeah no
that's true the wings were heavy but i
just want to talk about what they meant
to me i want to talk about how
abcd and then get to tell a story about
whatever you want to talk
um
but yeah you had some you had some
anecdotes batman
bamf uh yeah i have uh i have some
things that people said in chat because
i was
oh aldous is back hold on we're never
gonna get to talk to you
hey
yeah that was pretty ghetto uh my junk i
i'm uh
damn how did my computer just plugged up
in it
uh my computer apparently
died
even i got sitting here plugged up but
you know
want to be on that bush
uh uh
it happened to the best of us
obviously the best so
sir
yeah uh i was just saying that like you
get you get those moments of
levity of grace of gratitude
when you can ask a person a question
that they have been asked before you
know
that feeling of like
christ
excellent let's talk about watches
it's like you said it goes from q a to
conversation and uh
as you can tell i talk a lot i'm very
long-winded um but i enjoy having
conversation you know i'm trying to
discover something myself so like
you know yeah
what are we talking about
let's make an exchange of ideas
which is harder five minutes because
they got to get their quotes that they
know they got to plug into their story
but like yeah imagine being a journalist
because it's like hey three minutes you
have 45 questions to ask go like wait
what
yeah like the few times that i've
actually written stories for those
magazines um where it's a it's about a
profile it's about a person like i need
days i don't need hours i need days like
you got to let me just roll with this
person for a while you know let me hang
out gotta let me go to their work go to
their house let me like i need i need
hours just to [ __ ] talk
right i don't want to have to run down
this list of questions on my on my you
know [ __ ] index cards i want to just
talk to somebody get to know them and
then we'll get there we'll get around to
it
um
i remember once having to interview
christopher nolan
but dark knight rises and uh and
it was it was very cute we were at this
the this hotel in new york in chelsea
and uh and i was supposed to have tea
with christopher nolan and ask him a
couple questions
and then he was supposed to have one cup
of tea
and then once that cup of tea was over
the publicist was supposed to tap him on
the shoulder and say i'm sorry chris we
have to go to something else but then he
orders a second cup of tea
and then the publicist comes over it's
like are you okay so now i'm fine
i'm having a good time
like the it's the like you know your
your girl's like hey no the the whatever
something else happened we gotta yeah no
this is great but the car's on fire like
here's a signal that you've established
to extricate you from a scenario
um i'm sure you cannot tell me what's
next because that's just the way life is
what's next is the premier black adam
there it is well played
see what i like there is rejecting the
premise of the question
[Laughter]
and just saying what you want to say
anyway
yeah it's a false move we're working on
a lot of good things next but um
uh there's this there is
another project that i'm attached to
that
will probably be announced quite soon so
i can't say anything there
i will say this though i guess
uh
getting back to the anime uh because i i
just wrote anime that i'm really happy
about i see that
back and i was like
so um jumping on that because uh
i mean i have two companies i have hodge
bros productions with my family that's
more live action film television things
like that and then i have a company
called 9b collective it's an art studio
that i co-own with
michael wendy and phil boute jr and what
we do uh as a conceptual art studios
like
you know we work film television video
game animation um
illustration like if
dc has a another big film they're like
okay
here are the superheroes we're you know
talking about here's his story what does
it look like we're the guys who designed
the concept of
the world building the character
costumes all that kind of stuff you know
vehicles props we do all that
we are moving into different areas one
of them being our own
uh originally produced ip and that's uh
that's where we're going so this pilot i
just wrote is sort of a hybrid
collaboration
and uh
that's going to be one of our first
things out so we're working on that
right now i can't tell you what it is
exactly but that's all right those are
all all i wanted to know all i'm happy
to hear
is that we're going to get to see some
some alice hobbs joints out into the
world
you know the dude who wanted to make
this stuff is getting to make this stuff
the dude who wanted to be a [ __ ]
superhero is getting to be a goddamn
superhero like yeah
like yeah not only that you win the
lottery we get to win the lottery
because you want a lot
you're too kind brother
listen man you get back to your day it
seems like [ __ ] is about to pop off in
the other room maybe in a good way maybe
in a bad way
yeah i think it's a great she's she's
fine she's about to go to sleep
excellent all right well you go give
those kisses and you can have yourself
an excellent birthday man have a
fantastic press tour and we'll see you
on the other side all right brother
appreciate you thank you
and that boys and girls was alice hodge
um
okay and batman is back tell me some
stories okay maybe i maybe he'll pop
back in and i don't have to talk but
until that point
uh first off i just want to say as he's
closing out and he's talking about both
his production companies i think he's
talking about having a daughter he's a
martial artist he's an actor he makes
watches
does everybody else feel
completely lazy like i do like half
those things and don't have time to do
anything else i can't
even imagine
um but i
i wanted to share
uh
some people in chat
uh shin
akka cage says
uh aldus needs to remake passenger 57
that was when he was talking about all
of the uh martial arts uh braden gosey
said i'd love to see aldus kicking ass
as batman which i know you've always
said like
doesn't make sense for batman to be a
black guy because of the history but
like
i'd go watch him be batman
um
victor venn diagram said i kind of want
hodge to reboot born now
[Music]
then sean flum said about 650 people
just got an education and how to build
your professional life into your loves
which i thought was
yeah made sense but also like
you know uh like right on
uh
matt says please have him back on with
kevin for a five hour long show i bet
kevin will actually stay silent
and then
uh michael albert said at the end uh on
a podcast usually co-hosted by kevin
smith this man thinks he's long-winded
and he isn't completely wrong but we
love it
excellent
so i thought uh a ton of love for uh
eldest in the chat so much outstanding
yeah now he was it was so fun to talk to
and and the the beauty of it is that i
had no idea where we would be going
really like i didn't expect a 15-minute
detour into action cinema or anime or
any of that stuff but [ __ ] it let's go
let's talk about this i'm interested in
all of it
he uh i just
was mesmerized i i've never ever gone
back and re-watched a fat man beyond and
i think i've been doing this almost as
long as
you have
like i started six months after you were
the co-host of the show i've never
re-watched an episode and i was like i
think i got to go back and watch this
and take notes one word seriously like i
i do need that anime primer and he
seemed to to deliver it
um with passion and uh and and clarity
so yeah i'ma totally [ __ ] do that
um
it's funny at the top of the show even
before the top of the show you know when
al just hopped on i was like hey man we
can do one or two things like you can
just hop on as a guest and
you know we can we can talk about
whatever and then you can bounce out in
like you know half an hour 45 minutes
and then i'll go off and do the rest of
the show so you can just stick around as
a co-host and it's like i'll do the
whole show that'll be great and then
that didn't happen because he did have a
heart out and i don't think anybody told
him that this podcast tends to go at
least two hours
um
so uh so we're we we're going to do the
first version that he didn't think we
would do anyway but i kind of knew we
would in the back of my head
especially as we got to talking about
making watches
um which is fascinating to me
yeah i mean he didn't stay 15 minutes
past his heart out so he did it he did
give
he gave his bonus time because i think
he was having a good time and so i will
take it
um so yeah we are going to get into the
news um and then i guess we could do
some q a at the tail end of that um
but before we do that we have an ad to
read
um
this episode of
i was about to say fat man beyond but
it's not because it's only me here um
this episode of black man beyond is
brought to you by the good folks at blue
chew um
see i wish we could do a raise of hands
in the in the chat um
but then i'd have to be looking at the
chat to do that because i'm trying to
choose which of the two intros i should
read
um
i think i'll i'll uh i'll do this one
guys
it's
that summer heat into the bedroom
confidence can take you far in life it
can also help you in the boudoir
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate and that's where blue chew
comes in
luchu is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets at a fraction of the cost you
take them anytime day or night you can
plan ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises
the process is simple sign up at
bleaching.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days best parts all
done online so no business in the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
so with they say that first impressions
are important but what about lasting
impressions and to make a lasting
impression
you're gonna need some blue chew
so if you can benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
which you can help and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bleach you free when you use our promo
code fatman at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bleachy.com
promo code fatman to receive your first
month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bleach you for sponsoring this
podcast
all right let's get into some [ __ ]
news um there has been a little bit of
news um here and there um
uh i will say
that uh i am i'm caught up on house of
the dragons
i am not caught up on
um
lord of the rings ring some power so
i'll go too deep into them other than to
say like house of the dragon
still like maybe the one of the best
casts currently working on tv
um i do kind of wish that we would have
more to talk about in the show besides
um boy can i can we actually have a
queen
um women can't rule it's going to tear
the realm apart
i know
i know
um
so yeah i'm just
kind of i'm i'm waiting for the gears to
catch
um
but i'm still watching it's not like i'm
giving up i mean it's [ __ ] game of
thrones man of course i'm gonna watch um
so anyway the news
here's the thing i never expected to to
be able to say but i'm kind of glad that
i can
which is
um
keanu reeves is returning to play
constantine
um for a warner brothers sequel um
keanu reeves director francis lawrence
uh are both returning um akiba goldsmith
will write the screenplay and produce uh
as will j.j abrams and anna mangela from
bad robot
um
yeah man like
everything old is new again apparently
um and then of course some of the new
things we'll never see but um
of all of the bone-headed moves that
warner brothers discovery has made in
the past couple of months this does not
seem to be one of them at least not to
me
i was just gonna say everything old is
new again except for keanu reeves who
never has grown old
he remains evergreen
um
uh and you know god bless him i mean
john mc4 is coming we're getting another
constantine like
who who who knew
um i certainly didn't but i'm glad for
it
um the key renaissance is real and i'm
here for it um
in other news uh batman the caped
crusader
is uh shaking
its cal ass on the market um we talked i
guess a couple weeks ago about again
some of those previously mentioned
warner brothers discovery boneheaded
moves
is that uh warner brothers animation is
producing a an animated series a batman
animated series um executive produced by
bruce timm and ed brubaker um with matt
reeves the guy who directed uh no
relation to canada but he directed the
batman and jj abrams
um
they they're making a big ass [ __ ]
batman animated show
and uh
for some reason
hbo max decided they didn't want to air
said animated show and they have then
released warner brothers animation
to see if they can find another home for
it someplace else on the internet um
it seemed like a foregone conclusion
that somebody would want to air at
batman's show and it seems as if um
yes they are at the very least um having
lots of high profile meetings netflix
amazon and apple
seem to be the big contenders for where
it would go it was really never going to
appear on disney plus for any number of
reasons other than petty ones um and
it's not the best reason to make a
business decision but
um
as as theorized by uh both lots of
people on the internet and myself
um
we are at some point going to see this
show um which i hope we do because i
wrote an episode of it and i'd love to
be able to see it on my television um so
hopefully a some more clarity will come
in the coming weeks um as to where this
will land
but
i know they're still making it so
you know it'll be somewhere it'll have
to be somewhere
um
in other news i shouldn't introduce
every news item within other news
because that seems like it's a given but
anyway um stephen king's novel uh fairy
tale um recently um
dropped from uh scribner his publisher
and already uh there's a there's a
feature film adaptation in the works
paul greengrass who made uh
two of the three oh no four
he made three of the four porn movies
um uh he is now going to adapt it and
direct it um the novel is about uh it's
an epic tale that follows a 17 year old
boy who inherits the keys to a
terrifying world where good and evil are
at war uh the stakes could not be higher
for that world and hours as he journeys
into the mythic roots of human
storytelling
um
it is i believe it has been optioned in
the same way that most stephen king
stories are
it's a dollar
the dollar baby program remains alive
and well and it's always good to see
where
he will give you the rights for a dollar
for a certain amount of time
and then if you manage to make that
movie you owe him a giant chunk of money
in the back end
if you're a student filmmaker or an
amateur filmmaker you can still do it
for a dollar you just can't sell it to
anybody you can play festivals you can
win awards you can you can make it as a
presentation reel
but the minute you charge money for it
or the minute you try to sell it then
you know uncle stevie needs his cut um
but yes there will be another stephen
king movie uh from a new stephen king
novel on the way fairy tale
um
banff man himself jc had asked me this
question last week when we talked about
d23 it's like hey any word about rogue
squadron and they said no i hadn't seen
any uh kerfuffle anywhere about it
this week um it has announced that the
uh patty jenkins is road squadron
has been removed from the disney um
release slate it's no longer coming out
on december 22nd 2023
it remains in development but uh but at
this point nobody seems to be holding
their breath
in good star wars news the acolyte cast
is stacked like a [ __ ]
former good play star manny jacinto has
just been cast opposite amandla
steinberg
and
the newly minted emmy winner uh legion j
from uh from squid game
are all now in acolyte um it also uh
co-stars jody turner smith um leslie
hedland who's the show owner seems to be
putting together a murderer's row of
talent
which is for the acolyte a mystery
thriller
that uh will take viewers into a galaxy
of shadowy secrets and emerging dark
side powers in the final days of the
high republic era
um that sounds cool [ __ ] hell yeah like
give me a shiny ass cast of beautiful
people who are actually also very good
at their jobs and if you've never seen
the good place and you only saw like a
glimpse of manny jacinto in top gun
maverick because he got mostly cut out
of that movie
he's [ __ ] amazing so i i cannot wait
to see what this show is
um batman do you have any feelings about
the acolyte
uh i don't know
much anything about it i haven't really
followed that one
uh
i there's
i don't want to say i'm getting burnt
out but there's so
much out there
and like i am required daily to watch
finding nemo or cars or in
sesame street so like
you know
if you want me to sing the uh elmo's
world song i gotcha
uh
but
you know i like
you try to like squeeze stuff in on
sunday nights so i mean i'll watch it
but
i'm more hyped for andor
i know we got one more day till till
what three hours of andor in our face
yeah
yeah it's like it's a letter to squeeze
in there
are they episodes an hour long though i
feel like there's 13 episodes they gotta
be they're probably more she-hulk length
i would guess i don't know i mean it's
tony gilroy you know here's a dude who
like makes legit movies um and is trying
to tell this large story of rebellion
and
oppression
would not surprise me if you found ways
to fill in our
drama
you know what i heard i heard that uh
because they did the premiere uh which
of course we weren't invited to uh but
i i'm not surprised that i don't get
invited to lucasfilm things but um
the uh
i heard that
they used the word [ __ ]
in
the in star wars for the first time like
it's the first like
like hard cuss word that they use in
star wars
wow
so that was how i feel about that
i mean people pointed out there like han
solo says i'll see you in hell obi-wan
kenobi says what's that damn fool do or
han says what's that damn fool doing
about obi-wan so i guess there is kind
of precedent for it but like they just
they nudged it into you know
transformers the movie 1986 territory
yeah i mean it's it's it's less
it's fun i go both ways which like
absolutely human people it is a staple
of humanity the invention and and
careful deployment of profanity
um
and so i have no problem with anybody
who's a real person under real duress
um resorting to profanity to express
their emotions
um it's the it's the very terrestrial
very earth
[ __ ] that's the weird thing like not
that i want them to invent a curse word
that sounds shitty and silly
although
and they have never minded
well it's it's poo
job of the hutt says it in return of the
jedi and then they repeat it in the
prequel and stuff
not exactly like you want cassie and
andor like
life life hanging by a thread being like
oh poo
right but yeah but they do have a word
that exists for that thing
yeah i mean that also feels a bit like
you know a child's word for for
something like oh it's like doo doo it's
poo doo i get it
um
but you know that the frac solution took
some time to adjust to um from
battlestar galactica but it ultimately
did through repetition
work its way into you know not just the
show's fabric and and feel real but then
didn't work into the larger
version the the larger conversation
outside of the show
um but that requires a certain level of
commitment to it you can't just do it
once and drop it um so like i get it
from the same token an in-world version
of profanity um
feels good i tell you what it bothers me
less than
uh
in the
sequel trilogy that i'm saying godspeed
that gets under my skin a lot more
because i'm like
the force
or like when did the galaxy become a
monotheistic
place what god are we talking about
nobody's talked about a god before
so anyway other than cgpo who was a god
to these walks
but agod not the god
yeah right now
um
and let's see our final new story
is that
blade runner 2099
um has been picked up to series for
amazon prime video i'm ridley scott who
directed the original 1982 blade runner
is executive producing this live action
limited series
which is itself a follow-up to the
uh blade runner 2049 which was released
in 2017 and directed by denis
um
i mean [ __ ] it i i
i have been on record saying that i
didn't love the first movie and i was so
cold on the second movie
um i've since come around to both i
think it was during the pandemic that i
kind of sat down and watched them both
kind of back to back
um
and then i i think i appreciated them
more this time around than i than i had
in the past
simply as especially 2049
um
as it's just a it's a science fiction
novel like it's it's less doing a movie
it's less performing the things you
expect a movie to perform
and it's more going for this kind of
like impressionistic look
at
life as a as a replicant and what it
means and and the emotional contours of
it and it's
it's far more like jazz than it is rock
and roll and i i guess sometimes when i
come to movies i expect more rock and
roll um
but just just wallowing in that world
and in that sort of gentle character
portraits
and by gentle i mean violent um i
actually did appreciate quite a bit so
i'm looking forward to this like i'm i'm
looking forward to even getting to spend
more time
in that world um and accelerating that
story that you know began in 1982 um
which you know and i've always been of
the belief that even if i didn't love
blade runner um i could appreciate what
it is and what it means
um blade runner is a hugely important
movie um in the in the ongoing cinematic
evolution of science fiction um even if
for me it was never an emotionally
resonant one
um so i'm
thoroughly happy to see that blade
runners is coming back and it's going to
live
in another iteration
on the amazons on the primes
um so yeah that uh that's some good news
it feels like to me and
that's the end of the news he says
um
so yeah again that was it we had a
fantastic guest
we had a
short-winded ad for uh the the
stiffening
blue chew and then we covered some news
um do we have some q a we want to do
batman anybody around who wants to hang
out and chat
we can do a couple i i took some cues
during the uh during eldest so some of
these will be slightly adapted because
he's not here to answer anymore so but
he was here so i think we can
uh chime in
uh april kelly had wanted to know uh one
night in miami if either of them could
be in that room what is the one question
they would ask
if i could have asked
muhammad ali or jim brown or
malcolm x
or sam cook anything
where do they get their suits
that was the best dress cast i'd seen on
screen in a long while
um
and it seemed it seemed as if really
they had the questions well underhand in
wrestling with issues like
you know race and class and fame and
civil rights and progress
um
whereas i'm the schmuck who's gonna be
like hey man where can i get a suit that
looks that good on me um do they have a
big and tall section and whatever
against store it is
um and also where's the best barbecue
here in miami or where can i get some
great cuban food so i can not fit in the
suit that i just bought
um
but yeah i don't i don't i don't have
any
deep deep depth
that i want to plumb
with some of the greatest minds of the
20th century um
that would be silly for the [ __ ] lie
to be asking questions of muhammad ali
um although i did write a graphic novel
biography of muhammad ali
which i i was able to announce the
release date of which
it's a year away um so it's not pressing
news but yes the messenger
um the legend of muhammad ali is coming
from macmillan slash first second books
uh in april of 2023 so i'm very excited
about that i will i am sure
as i can talk more about it um i will
over the over the next 11 months leading
up to his publication um
but there is a chapter that is sent in
miami so
um
i guess i would ask muhammad ali how i
did in writing this chapter about his
life in which i made the most of it up
except for all the things that actually
happened
because that's what based on a true
story is
um
quick shout out to a lot of people in uk
and eu watching the show this week
because we did it early they were oh hey
outside
we had a morocco and a south africa
tuning oh [ __ ] as well so
that's kind of cool
well-meant um
how cool is the internet i mean we're
older
like can you imagine like before in real
time talking to somebody from cape town
south africa while you're talking about
nerd i mean
i just
very grandpa moment there but
it just strikes me as crazy sometimes
where'd he call it
that's not possible
shut up with your crazy future bucks
sorry jammin
um
uh paul hawkins wants to know
uh if you could have any co-hosts for
one episode alive or dead who would it
be and why
ooh alive or dead i think i'm going to
try and find somebody dead so as to not
piss off anybody a lot
um
i think
i think i would like to talk to
um
like
i'm i'm torn between like
ray harryhausen
and
isaac asimov
and
gene roddenberry no [ __ ] rod surly
i want to talk to rod sterling
like
i
i i've said it before i'll say it again
i'll say it until i die the twilight
zone is the greatest achievement in the
history of television um
it is a show
in which there are no standing sets
there are no recurring characters there
are no ongoing plots it is a short story
every week
none of it can be reused none of it can
be recycled
and and the hit rate on that show
is remarkable all of the all of the
crutches
that that regular serialized television
even regular episodic procedural
television have that show didn't have
and the fact that it ran for as long as
it did
is the fact that it was as good as it
was and the fact that more than half of
it was written by rod serlin himself
um along with a with a sort of coterie
of freelancers
um
remains
the single greatest achievement um
i mean some of them some of the episodes
were based on novels and he would in
fact get people you know like rich
matheson to come and write for him
you know write works sometimes based on
his own books and yes the freelancer
quote was deep and strong
but that is that is for better or worse
one man's singular vision and i think
it's very very very much for the better
um so to talk to rod serling about
writing that show inventing that show
producing that show about the challenges
and the hurdles and then the benefits of
not having to to
pay mind or heed to you know
these stories one sets up three or four
years ago that he may not have ever paid
off like hey man you weren't talking
about the internet
let's talk about you know fan
entitlement let's talk about
you know the pressure to ship two
characters that you never have to face
because that's not part of your story um
you know and it would also be great to
get like charlie brooker on that same
show
um to have you know rod sterling to have
these two guys these masters of the of
the anthology forum to talk about um
writing
similar or evocative shows
um
generations apart um would be
then i don't have to ask any questions i
just get to listen to charlie brooker
and brad sterling talk and just
slack jog gaze at them
that i think would be hilarious
um
but uh but yeah no roger [ __ ] it yeah
all right uh and then last question
which just came in that i thought was
interesting
uh jarvis brady
asked
uh have you ever been hit up by someone
whose work you have critiqued on either
fat man or black man
beyond
either to ask you for more opinions or
to give you their opinion on your
opinion
you ever get yourself uh
find yourself in that awkward situation
or in a situation where
you reaped praise on somebody and then
bumped into them at a party
um
i i have
i have
occasionally like rarely
um but it has happened that i've
stumbled into up against up against the
wrong but into somebody who's you know
um
whose movie or tv show i have had things
to say about
um
more often than not
it's been a perfectly wonderful civil
conversation
um
you know i i
think that
there's
there's things that i haven't liked
clearly there's things that i've talked
about not liking clearly there's things
that i've talked about ways that i might
have improved absolutely
it is not actually
often
that i've just called off and teed
something in the nuts because i thought
it was off um
i think that if if
i think to say so would be unfair
um
i have
i have been uh
approached by like my representatives my
managers my agent saying hey
do you want to take a meeting with this
person they've got this in development
and i'll say
no
because i did tee off on their not so
something that that person produced and
that is not a scenario that i want to be
um
that's going to end well for nobody so
let's pass on that
um i will say
one of the oddest things that that has
ever happened i had a meeting
um with tim crane
who was the showrunner of heroes creator
owner of heroes and was then running a
show that i was having this meeting
about during the staff of
called uh
called uh i won't say the name of the
show yet
um but
um sit down this meeting i go to his
house it's a lovely house in the
hollywood hills you know we we we have
our little pleasantries and we sit down
in his office and then we have what is
generally the content of a staffing
meeting
which is
they've read some of your script already
if not all of your script your sample
that your your reps are sent over so
they know that you can write or they
wouldn't have asked for the meeting um
so
those meetings are an hour long
generally
the first 45 minutes of it are you slash
me the person in this meeting trying to
get the job telling them who you are
what's your story you know where you're
from you know what's your path
um
you know and every person's story is a
different story and you know i because i
i'm an old ass person who came to this i
had a whole other life before becoming a
tv writer so there's a little bit of
story to tell
um
you know part of that story is always
my time as a journalist um which is
highlighted by the the 13 years that i
spent in entertainment weekly
so i'm talking to tim about it
and uh and he says oh entertainment
weekly it's like yeah now you guys gave
heroes a lot of love it's like yeah no
we love heroes like heroes you know
confidentially heroes was one of the
shows
that that was always a big seller for
the magazine so it was always going to
find ways to be in it like i'm sure we
put heroes on the cover like 90 times
because over the course of those seasons
it was always something that the
audience was was interested in he says
yeah no i remember we invited a writer
in to kind of spend some time and kind
of invest
with uh with um
you know
invest with the staff and just to get a
bird's-eye view of us making the second
season of the show
you know we mentioned the name of the
writer and i said i love that guy he's
amazing
you know he's a very good friend very
glad to see what he's gone on to in the
future
and then he says you know that uh
this the story that he wrote pretty much
destroyed the show what
he's like yeah that became the narrative
that you know whatever that that writer
had written was what everybody was
picking up on because nobody else had
the access that we gave you and then he
wrote a story that wasn't that great it
wasn't that flattering for us
and it became the thing that defined us
for a couple of years i don't think we
ever recovered from it
and so i in the middle of this meeting
have wedded myself to not just
entertainment weekly but to this
particular writer
which was in his eyes the downfall of
heroes
um
and then i found myself in a tailspin
that i'm not entirely sure that i ever
pulled out of i walked out of that
meeting you know called my reps it's
like yeah that's not getting that job
like i just it could not have gone worse
um
going gang bustles until it didn't and
then i i feel like i should shut the bed
some fierce so let's go find another job
and then two weeks later
um i get the offer to join the staff of
treadstone because apparently that did
not shift the bed um
as badly as i feared it did
um
so while that was not a specifically
thing that i had said about a person
being uh confronted by it was definitely
a
bad things were said about a person
um
and i was in some ways party to it
um but did not
actively or at least tim was a big
enough dude and a cool enough guy i had
a lot of blast working for tim
on treadstone but he was able to look
past that and see that maybe i might
have something to offer
um
that is probably the worst it's ever got
but i've
i think i've dodged the other time that
that might have been
equally uncomfortable
so
um and nobody's ever asked me for more
criticism the reason like i like the
things she had to say about that
um
but uh
tell me more
i didn't tell them more
um
which is probably better for all parties
concerned
um
but yeah i think is is that the last of
the jc have we have we plumbed the
depths of our questions that's that's
three
that's three he's he's answered this
question is three um which means that we
are bringing in this bird
at an hour 45 minutes
um it's like half a show
we should be here to warn you guys let's
order lunch
um
i hope you guys have enjoyed this
episode of black pantheon as much as i
did
because as i said at the top i've been a
fan of alice hodge from afar for a long
time i've glanced up against him
literally and physically
you know just once
um but to get to get to know him a
little bit to get to understand his
level of geekness and how it sort of
compares and contrasts with mind
um we don't have the same story but i
feel like you know there are enough
similar touch points
in our paths from you know
children of
caribbean parentage uh into people
getting to work in hollywood and make
their own dreams come true and who who
win the lottery by getting to do more
work and are bad at vacations um
uh it was it was lovely to get to know
him a little bit in front of all of you
i hope you got to know him as well
and are now as big of fans as i am
okay so thank you albus for uh for
taking the time off on your birthday
to uh to and away from a from a baby
girl who seemed like she wanted her dad
very badly
to talk to us about nerd [ __ ] so
thank you again and thank you to all of
you for you know this is it's
if you're in los angeles it's tuesday
morning if you're in you know the east
coast your tuesday afternoon and if you
are in as we said previously south
africa or you know the
north africa morocco or whatever um
good evening and thank you for for
tuning in we're real bad at this we also
have a live show on october 11th with
malcolm barrett from the boys i'm going
to do indeed
i'm going to put the
ticket link up right now as mark says
goodbye because
i'm failing
it's all good um yes malcolm barrett
will be back uh i'm not sure if we'll
have a show between now and then but you
know if if news continues to percolate
then maybe we will
bounce back on here for uh for a bit of
a black man
a mini black man beyond um
but hey thank you again for taking time
out of your day uh to hang out with me
and talk about nerd [ __ ] um
so that's it for this episode of black
man beyond my name is mark bernard uh
kevin smith is still off on the clerk's
three tour and uh you should go and see
him if he's gonna be the city near you
um because i i love that movie i'm in
that movie that's not why i love that
movie um
i think it might be my favorite kevin
smith
um people ask me all the time what's my
favorite and i always refuse to say i
think this might be it um so you should
go see it and go see it with him if you
can um
we'll be back uh same black time same
black channel
smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith
live long and prosper you guys
it's hard out there do a little living a
little along and prosper if you can
peace out
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith